en tunisie le sommet sur la francophonie
n'aura finalement pas lieu en novembre
il a été reporté à une date ultérieure
décision des 88 états membres motivés en
grande partie par la situation politique
instable voyez les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis bassem chili
il devait réunir dans l'île de djerba 88
états membres et associés pour deux
jours autour de la coopération
francophone le 18e sommet de la
francophonie est finalement reporté à
l'année prochaine une décision des
représentants des états membres annoncé
dans un communiqué publié hier sur le
site de l'organisation internationale de
la francophonie dans un souci de
cohésion et de solidarité avec la
tunisie qui vit actuellement une crise
politique majeure les états membres se
sont entendus pour proposer un report
d'un an afin de permettre à la jeune
démocratie d'accueillir ce rendez-vous
dans des conditions plus adéquate comme
l'annoncé le relief afin de pouvoir
valider rapidement cette proposition les
membres du conseil permanent de la
francophonie recommande la tenue dans
les plus brefs délais d'une session
extraordinaire de la conférence
ministérielle de la francophonie
une décision qui intervient alors que le
pays vient de se doter d'un gouvernement
après deux mois de tergiversations à la
suite du coup de force du président
saleh qui s'est octroyé les pleins
pouvoirs le 25 juillet dernier dans ce
contexte politique et économique des
plus fragiles la secrétaire général de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie la rwandaise louise
mushikiwabo
avait proposé après consultation avec
les autorités tunisiennes d'étudier la
faisabilité d'un tel événement la
tunisie elle de son côté avait réitéré
sa volonté sa capacité d'organiser un
tel événement malgré sa situation
économique difficile le report à l'année
prochaine du 18e sommet de la
francophonie devrait être ratifié dans
les jours à venir lors de la prochaine
conférence ministérielle de
l'organisation